[Música]
bienvenidos a ello soy de france24 hay
rechazo internacional por la decisión de
turquía de abandonar el convenio de
estambul es diseñado para luchar contra
la violencia machista el gobierno de
reyerta llíber dogan salió del pacto que
firmó en 2011 y al que pertenece de 34
miembros del consejo europeo alegando
que normaliza la homosexualidad y que es
incompatible con los valores sociales y
familiares de turquía tras el anuncio
miles de mujeres mantienen protestas de
rechazo y es que en 2020 se registró el
asesinato de 300 mujeres a manos de sus
parejas o exparejas
el convenio de estambul no sólo está en
el centro del debate por la salida de
turquía que fue el primer país en
firmarlo en 2011 sino también porque
muchas naciones que critican la decisión
tampoco aplican las premisas del acuerdo
en este informe de más romeros revisamos
que dice el documento y qué hacen los
países firmantes al respecto
es un referente pero sobre el papel el
convenio de estambul aprobado por el
consejo de europa en 2011 es el primer
pacto internacional vinculante que busca
prevenir y combatir la violencia contra
la mujer
criminaliza desde el acoso y la
violencia económica hasta la mutilación
genital femenina y considera violación
cualquier relación sexual sin
consentimiento explícito un paso más
allá que muchas legislaciones estatales
los países que lo firman según el
convenio se considerarán responsables si
no responden de manera adecuada a la
violencia machista pero no hay ninguna
sanción para los que no cumplan las
obligaciones del tratado solo informes
que evalúan su desempeño y que se
realizan cada varios años en total 34
países han ratificado el tratado turquía
es el primero en abandonarlo pero hay
otros países que no ven claros sus
postulados polonia también quiere
retirarse hungría y bulgaria no lo han
ratificado y rusia y azerbayán se
negaron a firmarlo en su momento sin
embargo entre los países que sí lo han
ratificado y que ahora lo defienden hay
muy pocos que hayan adaptado su
legislación al marco del convenio son
países como grecia suecia o países bajos
y en españa' está en debate con mucha
oposición una ley que ampliaría lo que
se considera violación en los mismos
términos que los del tratado
pero el debate llegó por la presión del
movimiento feminista y no por cumplir el
convenio de estambul
para analizar este tema nos acompaña
desde madrid' de españa la analista
marta gonzález ella está especializada
en relaciones internacionales en oriente
medio y en geopolítica marta bienvenida
a ellas hoy y quiero comenzar sin demora
hablando del documento es un marco legal
común y vinculante pero no habla por
ningún lado de homosexualidad como
argumento turquía de lo que se habla es
de no discriminar por orientación sexual
para usted desde su postura de analista
es aceptable anteponer la moral
conservadora de una parte del país por
encima de los derechos humanos
hola buenas tardes en primer lugar es un
placer estar ante ustedes en este
programa y ante el público de que ve su
programa y bueno es muy muy muy contenta
de estar participando en este un honor
participar en este en este debate
efectivamente como han señalado en el
reportaje es un tratado internacional
vinculante que tiene además su
importancia en el sentido de que por
primera vez en el marco europeo y en el
espacio europeo establece los estándares
internacionales de lo que tiene que ser
la defensa de los derechos de la mujer y
en contra de la violencia contra la
mujer y la violencia doméstica en este
sentido es cierto que en el ámbito
europeo en el ámbito de la unión europea
sobre todo
regímenes jurídicos por decirlo de
alguna manera atrás han traspuesto a sus
ordenamientos jurídicos normativas en
defensa de los derechos de la mujer
desde hace ya 20 años el problema viene
se viene planteando en esos o en esas
otras sociedades que se han ido
incorporando al marco europeo pero que
no forman parte de los estándares que
tenemos aquí estamos acostumbrados en
europa occidental como bien han
mencionado azerbaiyán turquía bulgaria
parte de grecia etcétera hay países
incluidos dentro del marco de la unión
europea como es polonia que tienen
serias reticencias para adaptar
legislaciones que consideran lesivas
para su cultura o incluso para sus
ordenamientos jurídicos y en el caso que
me que menciona en el caso de turquía
que es quizá el más importante desde el
punto de vista
físico es hemos materializado la
frustración de la salida de un país que
aparentemente tiene se mantiene o vive
en una diatriba entre el laicismo y la
islamización constante
y cada vez más más acuciante pues es lo
que nos ha dejado un poco sorprendidos
pero para los analistas no nos veíamos
tan claro que no no fuera a salir de un
tratado que firmó efectivamente en 2011
y bueno él lo firmó 2011 y lo ratificó
en 2012 pero que en ningún momento el
presidente erdogán tenía muy claro que
era siempre siempre tuvo muy claro que
es un convenio un tratado que va en
contra de la idiosincrasia del país la
señora martha esto también hay que verlo
dentro del contexto político entonces es
un tema primero de una turquía que
quiere ser más parte del bloque europeo
pero además es una turquía que en este
momento con erdogán a la cabeza necesita
más apoyo electoral para poder seguir en
el poder y ahí podríamos de pronto
explicar un poco esos cambios pero más
allá de eso qué pasa con los países
firmantes
que no están aplicando a cabalidad el
convenio que no han hecho cambios
efectivos realmente radicales en sus
legislaciones para defender a las
mujeres de la violencia machista
este convenio realmente ha servido en la
proporción que debería servir en todos
estos años
vamos a ver efectivamente suscita serias
dudas en determinados sistemas jurídicos
por ejemplo en el caso más cercano que
tenemos en mi caso es el español durante
más de 20 años
la misma constitución consagra en la
parte de derechos fundamentales el
respeto la igualdad la libertad
etcétera entre hombres y mujeres como un
derecho fundamental el tribunal supremo
en nuestro país en 2018 ya por sentencia
del tribunal supremo determinó que había
una asimetría jurídica y que la carga de
la prueba pues se caía casi siempre en
el varón y se invertía es decir en las
críticas en el caso de europa occidental
donde los sistemas jurídicos son
avanzados y donde el derecho de la mujer
está garantizado en todos los órdenes
las críticas vienen por la intromisión
en los sistemas jurídicos de la de
asociaciones de muy radicales feministas
más radicales podríamos decir que lo que
se conoce como el feminismo de cuarta
ola pero es no es necesario asumir que
todas las feministas de la cuarta ola
son feministas radicales yo pensaría que
eso es demasiado demasiado acelerado
decirlo y por eso más bien le pregunto
su posición como mujer porque si bien es
claro que puede que en muchos países de
europa occidental sobre el papel los
derechos de las mujeres estén
garantizados pues eso no está pasando
porque el feminicidio sigue siendo una
realidad porque la violación sigue
siendo una realidad porque incluso los
casos de mutilación genital femenina aún
desde europa no se han logrado erradicar
y nos siguen afectando entonces usted
como lo ve desde su posición ya no como
analista ya no como académica sino como
mujer
claro efectivamente el convenio el
convenio de estambul lo que hace es una
diferencia una catalogación por primera
vez y una categorización de lo que es
violencia de género y violencia en el
ámbito doméstico familiar y ahí es donde
tenemos las dudas donde suscita las
dudas en aquellas sociedades que son más
conservadoras en el ámbito español por
ejemplo el labio en las mutilaciones no
están a la orden del día salvo en
sociedad en grupos muy particulares que
provienen de sociedades extranjeras
afincadas en europa y nuestros códigos
penales
y lo condenan y además lo criminalizan
es decir está contemplado en la cuestión
yo creo que si nos referimos al ámbito
de turquía yo creo que más allá de las
de la aplicación en europa el problema
que suscita que países que no tienen un
concepto de democracia tan asad han
afincado tan asentado como las
sociedades occidentales puedan verse
pueda significar un retroceso a la hora
de penalizar unas prácticas que están
toleradas desde el punto de vista social
y ahí es donde creo que debemos poner el
foco porque efectivamente en la parte
occidental donde vivimos las mujeres de
forma democrática
no tenemos esos problemas a la hora de
determinar que un problema que una
violación tiene que estar penalizada por
los códigos civiles y penales el
problema yo creo que se suscita en
aquellas sociedades donde estas
prácticas están toleradas del
desgraciadamente desde el punto de vista
social y cultural y turquía es uno de
los países que en estos momentos se
debate entre una islamización cada vez
más rampante más importante más más
digamos más contundente es un guiño
también a la sociedad a los partidos
conservadores y desde luego supone una
fractura con aquella parte de la
sociedad turca civil laica que tiene que
viene del espíritu de la turquía de
atatürk y que mira con bastante
preocupación el proceso de islamización
de su país pues se le agradezco mucho
por sus opiniones y por sus impresiones
2b pequeños comentarios para el cierre y
es que por un lado aunque estén escritas
las leyes en el papel en europa más que
en otros países que de pronto tienen
otras tendencias religiosos y morales
efectivamente los derechos de la mujer
aún no se cumplen y no están plenamente
garantizados y continúan con nosotros en
france24 nos vemos próximamente en ella
surge
[Música]